schön brücken erhoben es laden das war
ja wichtig nicht mehr gestern diskutiert
wurde in der sache allerdings wenig
neues muss man sagen argumente die man
schon kannte die opposition gibt der
ampel regierung die schuld so dass sie
keinen eigenen antrag also wie gesagt da
wurden die alten argumente ausgetauscht
in der sache nicht viel neues der
entscheidende punkt ist aber ob so eine
impfpflicht wenn sie denn kommen würde
überhaupt verfassungskonform wäre
da haben sie recht das ist das nicht der
entscheidende punkt die politik ist frei
aber sie muss sich an die grenzen der
verfassung halten und aus meiner sicht
ist tatsächlich die ihm schlicht
verfassungswidrig
sie ist eben kein kleiner pieks wie
manchmal gesagt wir sollen sie sagen
deutlicher eingriff ganz viele
grundrechte nicht nur in das grundrecht
auf körperliche unversehrtheit auch in
andere grundrechte und das erlaubt die
verfassung nur unter besonderen
bedingungen
und diese bedingungen sehe ich im
augenblick nicht ausgegeben hat reicht
den ihrer meinung nach das argument
eines überlasteten gesundheitssystems
was es ja auch momentan gar nicht gibt
das sind sozusagen zwei punkte der erste
punkt ist ja die verfassung gesagt dem
start du hast die pflicht die gesundheit
und das leben auch seiner bürgerinnen
und bürgern zu schützen insofern muss
der staat eine ein funktionierendes
gesundheitssystem unterhalten aber die
frage ist ob die impfpflicht dafür
überhaupt geeignet ist eine mögliche wir
reden ja nicht von der tatsächlichen
überlastung sondern von einer möglichen
überlastung des gesundheitssystems
das problem ist glaube ich seit omikron
sind die spielregeln an dass die impfung
wirkt fast gar nicht mehr gegen promikon
das sieht man an zahlen gucken sich
portugal oder bremen dass das sind zwei
staaten haben eine unglaublich hohe
impfquoten da gibt es praktisch keine im
flügge und trotzdem gehen die instanzen
durch die decke das heißt möglicherweise
sind die impfstoffe die wir gerade haben
gar nicht geeignet das ziel zu erreichen
nämlich die ansteckung zu verhindern und
dann darf man natürlich die bürger nicht
mit einer pflicht belegen sich dann
trotzdem impfen zu lassen und dann
bleibt noch die frage sollte eine
endlich kommen wie kann die überhaupt
kontrolliert werden
sie haben auch recht eine pflicht nutzt
nur dass nur dann was wenn man sie auch
kontrollieren kann und das ist natürlich
ganz schwierig
wir müssten der staat müsste dann wissen
welcher bürger welche bürgerin hat sich
wie oft impfen lassen das würde ein
unglaublich umfangreiches register
erfordern über ganz sensible
gesundheitsdaten wir reden ja nicht über
irgendwelche daten oder wir reden da
über intime gesundheitsdaten und das
kann man denke ich praktisch schon gar
nicht in der kürze der zeit aufbau und
fach und was den datenschutz angeht der
ja auch von der verfassung garantiert
wird halte ich das für ganz
problematisch einfach unglaublich viele
intime persönliche daten zu sammeln dass
das sehe ich gerade nicht wie das gehen
soll anordnungen von professor boehme
neßler vielen dank dafür ich
danke ihnen